George Clooney is very good friends with
your husband Randy and I understand that
those two enjoy going out on the town
together sometimes having a few drinks
is that fair to say they have been known
to go up and have a few tequilas
yes and it's got a little out of hand at
some point I understand yes George is
very well behaved now that he's married
to the lovely Amal so but a press
release okay there was there was a time
before he met him all that he and Randy
had gone out and they they did ask me if
I want to come but it was a Sunday night
and I stayed home with the kids and
sometimes if Randy goes out late he'll
go into the guest room in the kit
because the kids will end up falling to
sleep with me in my room
and so I got up because I wanted to make
sure he was home safe and I went in the
guest room and I see Randy like face
down on the bed and I'm like oh and he
still has his motorcycle boots on and
I'm like really like so I go over I get
on the bed I'm like hey babe and he
looks and it wasn't Randy and I don't
know who was more shocked to me or
George because you know I've woken
George about of a dead slightly
inebriated slumber mmm-hmm and so he's
like oh my god and and I was like oh my
god and then I ran it what were you
doing this for you I wasn't - you were
only wearing a snake
I was covered but not as much as I would
have normally been covered if I thought
I was waking up George Clooney so I run
out I find and I find Randy and I wake
him up because now I'm like everyone
else is awake
he was in my daughter's room I'm like
what why is George in our guest room and
why didn't you tell me and then we hear
George get up wandering around he
decides to go down to the kitchen so
then I hear Randy go down there laughing
so then I go down and we just all left
and we thought how funny would have been
if the light wouldn't have been on right
cuz I would have just got in bed and
then we were saying how would George and
I have explained that in the morning
like George and I wake up we just like
to walk out of the guest room and
Randy's like what is going on here I
just know there are many ways in which
I'm not George Clooney many ways but one
is that if you mistakenly thought I
would I was your husband and nudged me
I'd be like yes I am your husband yes I
am Randy
[Applause]